Thank you so much for being
here. Congrats on this show.
-Thank you. Thank you so much.
-So you -- In the first episode,
you play sort of
an acting teacher at a school.
You run the theater program.
And you have to take a back seat
in the first episode
because a new acting teacher
comes in, played by Josh Radnor.
-Yes. I-I -- My character,
Tracey Wolfe,
has been working at that
high school for 20 years
as the assistant drama director
and has been waiting for
the drama director
to either die or retire...
-Uh-huh. [ Laughs ]
-...so she can take the job.
And the woman retires,
and she gets passed over
for Josh Radnor's character.
And when the show premiered
last week,
there was so much
on social media.
People were so upset, you know,
and I feel that it was good that
they were upset, you know.
This show was written
prior to Time's Up.
-Yeah.
-Right?
But Time's Up is here.
And I was really happy that
people were so angry about it.
You know?
And I think that when they
continue to watch the series,
they're gonna see Tracey
really stick up for herself,
because in real life,
it doesn't happen,
somebody tells somebody off
and then they get
the right position.
It doesn't happen that way.
Real life is a lot messier.
And most people can't just quit
their job and find another one.
-Sure.
-Or tell off the principal
and still retain their job
and their position.
-Yeah.
-So, you know,
I was actually really happy.
I was happy that people were
pissed off.
-Good. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I'd be pissed off if you got...
[ Cheers and applause ]
if you got overlooked as well.
And you -- you pulled a lot
of your past to play Tracey,
because you started -- What is
it, the Urban Arts Partnership?
Is that your organization?
-Yes, I started -- I co-founded
Urban Arts Partnership
25 years ago.
We're an arts ed charity,
and we service
only Title I schools.
That means schools at or below
the poverty line.
And we go directly inside
the schools
and we work with the principals.
We review
the academic curricula.
And we have our programs.
Our programs have the students
help them comprehend
the academics.
So it's not just
art for art's sake.
It's arts for education.
And so I've been doing this
for 25 years.
I get this script and I just
started crying,
and my husband was like,
"What -- what's wrong now?"
[ Laughter ]
You know? [ Laughs ]
And -- and I said,
"I can't believe that
my personal life is meeting
my professional life."
-That's wonderful.
-"This is gonna be a breeze."
And I remember
I told my manager, I said,
"Call NBC and say this is mine."
[ Snapping fingers ]
[ Laughter ]
"This is mine."
-So I'm glad it worked out.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, you... [ Clears throat ]
you were a beneficiary of people
who sort of reached out
and were helpful as well
when you were young.
-Yeah.
-You -- you learned to dance
and play baseball...
-Yeah.
-True story -- from nuns.
-That's correct.
-Wow.
-Yeah. Yeah. I was --
I was a ward of the state.
And I was also in foster care.
But prior to getting into
foster care,
I was in
a Catholic home for children.
And the nuns,
first day they were like,
"You need to be on the stage."
And I was like, "No, I don't."
You know, I was a little kid.
And they kept forcing the issue.
And they taught me how to tap.
They taught me --
Well, they taught me ballet,
but they wouldn't let me be
in the ballet recitals
'cause they said I was too short
and my thighs were too chunky.
-No. Well. that's...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-That doesn't seem like
a very nun thing so say.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, but the best thing
they did was, um,
teach me how to play baseball
because I ended up being
on the Little League,
girl's Little League.
-And I would not have believed
that nuns taught people
how to play baseball,
but you brought this photo,
and that is proof right there.
That is...
[ Laughter ]
That is nothing
if not a nun playing baseball.
[ Laughs ]